من باب المصالحه قد يعود الامير هاري الى
اروقه قصر باكينجا لكنها قد تكون عاجله
قبل تتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث مايو
المقبل وفقا لصحيفه ساندي تايمز
البريطانيه
اجتماعا قد يعقد بينهما في حضور وريث
العرش الامير ويليام خلال الاشهر المقبله
رغبه حقيقيه لجلوس الشقيقين مع الملك
تشارلز في غرفه واحده
ومصالحه ممكنه لكن تقف في طريقها عقبات
حسب تقرير صنداي تايمز تتطلب المصالحه
الاعتراف باخطاء الماضي من قبل الجميع وهو
ما يحتاج الى مرونه قد يفتقدها هاري
الراغب في الحصول على اعتذار من العائله
الملكيه لزوجته الى جانب المساءله قبل
المصالحه
العقبه الثانيه تتمثل في نيران كتاب
البديل التي جعلت الامير وليام يحترق
داخليا حسب وصف المصدر المقرب من الجانبين
فهل يستطيع وريث العرش الحفاظ على هدوء
بعد تركومات الخلاف مع شقيقه هاري
غياب الثقه المتبادله يظل حاجزا ليس فقط
من اجل اتمام المصالحه ولكن من اجل الجلوس
اولا فبحسب المصادر ينبغي وجود افراد من
الاسره يثق فيهم هاري حتى لا يعتقد انه
يتعرض ما
عقبه نحو المصالحه يسعى القصر الى تذليلها
وملك يرغب في تهيئه اجواء طبيعيه خلال
مراسم التتويج في ماي المقبل وان لم تهدا
الاجواء فقد تتحول الى مصدر الهاء وتشتيت
وفقا لمقربين من العائله الملكيه
علي السمان العربيه